so you know now I want to talk about
post-modernism a little bit what seems
to me that's much Michelle Foucault in
the middle and a more reprehensible
individual you could hardly ever
discover or even dream up no matter how
twisted your imagination and Foucault
and Derrida I would say there's more but
I would say they're the two architects
of the of the of the post modernist
movement and in brief I think what they
did was in the late 60s and early 70s
they were avowed Marxist some way way
after anyone with any shred of ethical
decency had stopped being a Marxist by
that time even jean-paul Sartre had
woken up enough to figure out that the
Soviets hadn't assured in the kingdom of
heaven you know he had evidence
stretching back 45 years that he could
have attended to if he would have been
willing to open his eyes talk about bad
faith which was his critical critique
essentially is something quite
staggering the post modernists knew that
they were pretty much done with regards
to pushing their classic Marxism by the
late 60s in the early 70s because the
evidence that
stellen this Russia not only Stellina
certainly Lenin was no no saint by any
stretch of the imagination that the
killing certainly got underway while he
was still alive and and continued after
Stalin was dead as well although perhaps
with not the same degree of brutality
and efficiency and then there is of
course Mao is China where the estimates
you know nobody knows how many people
died under Mao but the estimates are run
as high as a hundred million people
which actually turns out to be quite a
few people and the fact that we can't
keep count accurately you know without
an error margin of something in the tens
of millions just tells you exactly how
horrible the situation was they
transformed the Marxist dialogue of rich
versus poor into oppressed versus
oppressor and Foucault in particular who
never fit in anywhere and who was an
outcast in many ways and a bitter one in
a suicidal one his entire life did
everything he possibly could with his
staggering IQ to figure out every
treacherous way possible to undermine
the structure that would
accept him in all his peculiarities and
it's no wonder because there would be no
way of making a structure that could
possibly function if it was composed of
people who were is peculiar bitter and
resentful as Michel Foucault so you
couldn't imagine this functioning
society that would be composed of
individuals with his particular makeup
in any case he did put his brain to work
trying to figure out a how to resurrect
Marxism under a new guys let's say and
be how to justify the fact that it
wasn't his problem that he was an
outsider it was actually everyone else's
problem and he did a pretty damn good
job of that and laid the groundwork for
this for the what would you call it the
rise of the marginalized against the
center and Derrida's thinking is very
much the same you know Darren even
though Foucault and Derrida hated each
other and and regarded each other as
intellectual charlatans which was about
the only thing either of them was ever
really correct about so Derrida was also
and Derrida in some ways is even a more
treacherous thinker because he makes the
claim in some sense that like a
political system has a center around
which the majority congregate let's say
it's it's it's quite similar to two
fuko's analysis and that there are there
are people who are outside the category
system and then which is obviously true
because no matter how you categorize
people there are certain people inside
the category and certain people outside
that's actually why you categorize
things right because of every category
holds every entity then every every
cognitive operation is infinitely
complex you can't manage that way to
categorize you have to include and
exclude it's in the very nature of
categorization and you can't just scrap
categorization because without
simplification and categorization you
actually can't function in the world you
just die right you die of excess stress
it's something like something like that
happens to schizophrenic people because
their category systems break down
they're completely incapable of
functioning in the world as a
consequence of that anyways then foo you
know there
I went Adam Fuko as well went a step
farther and this is one of the
incredibly crooked elements of their
thinking I think another sleight of hand
which was well category systems exclude
political systems exclude economic
systems exclude any hierarchy of value
excludes obviously because if there was
a hierarchy of value some things are
more valuable than others and the less
valuable things are excluded because
otherwise it wouldn't be a hierarchy of
value but the next claim they
essentially make is that the reason that
those hierarchies of value are
constructed isn't to produce whatever it
is that's of value but to exclude and to
maintain the structure of power that's
intrinsic to the hierarchy of value and
that's a that's an unbelievably crooked
claim because there are multiple reasons
why a hierarchy value might be put into
place their hierarchies of beauty and
there's hierarchies of competence
hierarchies of intelligence and and
attractiveness and
and athletic ability and musical talent
there's multiple hierarchies and in
order for those things to exist at a
high order in order for us to to do laud
what would you say musical genius we
have to excuse all the people we have to
exclude all the people who can only
squawk their clarinet from the hierarchy
because otherwise you don't have any
music and there's no up and there's no
direction and so to claim that the
purpose of the hierarchy is to exclude
is unbelievably crooked and it's a
central claim for both for both Foucault
and and Derrida it's one of those
slights of hands that people don't quite
notice but that have absolutely
catastrophic effects now for Foucault
and Derrida they you could here's how
you could imagine their world
essentially you know for the for the
philosopher Hobbes life was nasty
brutish and short and people were at
each other's throats in the state of
nature right but Hobbes really thought
about that as a as a has the chaos of
individuals and he believed that a
central authority had to exert force in
order to organize that intrinsic chaos
so that some degree of peace could reign
it's kind of the opposite of
jean-jacques Rousseau's theory which was
that human beings were intrinsically
good and and
the state the the government was
intrinsically bad and that all of what
made people evil derive from the state I
would say if you put Hobbes and Russo
together you actually get the truth even
though they do seem to be coming at it
from opposite perspectives because
people are actually good and evil and
social structures are also good and evil
and you know it's paradoxical and we
don't like paradoxical categories but
that's still how it is what what
Foucault and Derrida and the post
modernists did was that they kind of
added a collective element to that so
they're Hobbesian world isn't a world of
individuals struggling against one
another in the initial state of warlike
nature it's it's groups of individuals
bound by whatever their identity happens
to be struggling against these each
other for power because in the
postmodern neo-marxist universe there's
nothing but power and there's a variety
of reasons for that partly it's because
the post modernists don't admit that
there are any standards outside of
arbitrary opinion essentially they don't
really believe in the real world which
is why they can generate critiques of
science for example which is
increasingly characterized as nothing
but part of the Eurocentric patriarchy's
what would you call desire to impose
their power structure on the rest of the
world despite the fact that it also
makes planes fly and computers operating
and well you know yeah exactly
so and it's a rare bloody social justice
warrior that doesn't have an iPhone or a
Android that wouldn't work if quantum
mechanics wasn't actually correct
because the fact that quantum mechanics
is correct is one of the reasons why
these unbelievably highly developed
pieces of technology actually functions
so they bitch and whine about the
patriarchal patriarchal underpinnings of
Eurocentric science and use the gadgets
all the time to aggregate to complain
about it so it's really pretty appalling
so anyways anyways the worldview of the
of the postmodern neo-marxists is that
everybody is basically not an individual
because that's really a fiction and
Eurocentric patriarchal fiction at that
but I'm
member of whatever their identity group
happens to be and there's no real
possibility of communication between
identity groups hence phenomenon like
cultural appropriation and so it's a war
of all groups against all groups and
it's all it's nothing but a struggle for
power and there's no higher order ethic
to be referred to because for the post
modernists there is no such thing as a
higher order ethic there's no such thing
as a uniting narrative that's that's a
hallmark of their thinking now of course
that doesn't work out in practice
because without an ethic or a
higher-order value there isn't anything
you can do with your life because you
keep undermining yourself if
everything's just a whim and subjective
there's and there's no hierarchy of
values then what the hell do you do when
you get up in the morning if one thing
isn't better than the other you might as
well just lay there and smother yourself
with a pillow would be a lot easier than
opening your eyes and struggling in the
world so so it's completely it's a
self-defeating philosophy and I think
that's part of the reason why it's more
or less self-evident that it's a mask
for the continuation of Marxism because
at least Marxism has as one of its
advantages a direction it's an ethic
right you have something to struggle
against even though what you're
struggling against is certainly one of
the things that you actually rely on and
second something that you have to
oversimplify in a very ungrateful and
resentful way to justify fighting
against it to begin with
and that's especially true in Western
cultures because as pathological as they
certainly are which is approximately as
pathological as all of you are there are
a lot less pathological than almost
everything that's ever happened and
pretty much everything that's currently
happening elsewhere in the world and you
can kind of tell that by the fact that
people tend to cut to emigrate to the
West rather than the reverse now you
know the postmodern neo-marxists would
have an answer to that which would be
the only reason the West functions is
because it's raped the rest of the of
humanity and the planet but you know the
less said about that the better